Hallo, mein Name ist Elif Beisartonung. Ich bin hier als Assisten-Ersten hier in der
Station tätig und würde gerne lassen Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden? Ja, Hauptsache, jemand hilft mir.
Okay, kurz zum Ablauf. Ich werde Ihnen zuerst ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person
stellen. Dann komme ich in die Woche zu Ihren Aktuellen beschwerden.
Wie heißen Sie denn? Ich heiße Jochen Schäfer.
Können Sie bitte langsam buchstabieren? Der Vorname ist Jochen, J, U, C, H, E, N.
C, H, I, N. Jochen. Jochen?
Und der Familienname ist Schäfer. S, C, H, A, U, F, E, R.
Ja, und sind Sie Herr Schäfer? Herr Steinmann, ja.
Wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 48.
48 und sind Sie geworden? Am 17.04.77.
77. Und wie groß sind Sie?
83. Wie viel wegen Sie tut es seit?
90 Kilo ungefähr. Und was fühlt es denn tun Sie?
Das ist vor zwei Stunden losgegangen. Ich habe mit einmal solche
wahnländigen Schmerzen in der rechten, hier im rechten Rücken,
so im unteren Rücken. Und das strahlt also in die Leiste aus
und ich habe mit einmal auch ganz leute Schmerzen,
wenn ich Wasser lassen muss. Ich habe auch gesehen,
dass der Urin ganz blutig ist. Und das ist verrückt.
Ich muss gar nicht viel auf die Toilette, aber ich muss ständig,
habe ich das Gefühl, ich muss laufen.
Das kommt immer so ein ganz bisschen und es tut unsäglich weh.
Und wie können Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind die Schmerzen eher krampfartig, willen für mich, oder?
Also diese Schmerzen im Rücken, das sind so krampfartige Schmerzen.
Ja, und beim Wasserlassen, dass der Brennt ist ganz doll, ne?
Wir schmerzen auch eine Schmerzkarte von 1 bis 10, wobei alles
ganz leichte und sehr starke Schmerzen entspricht.
Also ich bin wirklich hart im Nehmen, würde ich sagen.
Ich denke, das sind so, also bei 18 die Bestimmten.
8, 2 und 10 und beim Wasserlassen.
Bitte was?
Beim Wasserlassen. Wie stark diese Schmerzen?
Ja, das Brennt, das ist halt immer nur kurz, aber das ist auch sehr heftig.
Das ist nicht viel weniger, das ist vielleicht bei 7 oder so.
Okay, und sind Sie gegen, damit sind Sie gegen etwas eingenommen
oder etwas versucht?
Na, ich habe noch gar nichts eingenommen.
Das hat ja eben gerade erst mehr oder weniger angefangen,
vor Kurzem, also diese starke Schmerz.
Das Brennt beim Wasserlassen, das habe ich ja eigentlich schon den ganzen Tag
und habe mir aber nichts Böses dabei gedacht.
Na ja gut, kann ja mal passieren.
Aber jetzt diese Rhythmeschmerzen, das ist wirklich so heftig.
Nee, also ich habe noch nichts eingenommen dagegen.
Okay, und diese Schmerzen nur rechte Seite, oder?
Ja, ja, ja, auf der rechten Seite, also in rechten unteren Rücken so.
Und ausschalen in die Leiste?
Und in die Streit, ja.
Ja.
Und haben Sie schon mal das erlebt, diese Schmerzen?
Solche Schmerzen nehmt, das habe ich wirklich noch nie erlebt.
Und gibt es vielleicht eine Auslöser für diese Schmerzen?
Es fällt mir nichts zu ein. Also das fing an schlachtartig jetzt, ja.
Und sind Sie übel?
Ob mir übel ist.
Ja, also ich musste mich tatsächlich einmal übergeben vorhin,
ja, aber ich glaube, das kommt wirklich von den Schmerzen,
weil es ist sehr intensiv.
Haben Sie nur eine Zeit übergeben?
Einmal, ja.
Einmal übergeben.
Und wie sieht der Erbrochen aus?
Das Erbrochene, wie das immer aussieht, das sind die Reste von dem,
was man gegessen hat und so ein bisschen gelblich, bitter, fies, eklig, ja.
Und haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang?
Normalerweise überhaupt nicht, nein.
Und müssen Sie häufig tot Holette gehen?
Nein, üblicherweise nicht, aber jetzt natürlich, ja.
Jetzt, okay.
Und normalerweise schaffen Sie gut?
Normalerweise schlafe ich gut, ja,
aber heute Nacht kann ich mir das nicht vorstellen, ja.
Und wie sieht Ihr Appetit aus?
Normalerweise ist der gut, aber heute eben nicht.
Heute nicht, okay.
Und waren Sie in dieser Zeit im Ausland?
Ausland?
Nee.
Ja, ich habe einmal Urlaub in Dänemark gemacht,
aber das ist jetzt ein paar Wochen lang.
Wann war das?
Im Mai, Anfang Mai.
Und sind Sie vorstellig geimpft?
Ja, klar, bin ich geimpft, ja, ja, ich habe.
Und haben Sie eine Vorerkaukung?
Also, man hat festgestellt, dass ich ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe,
ja, und dann...
Bitte?
Das hat man vor vier Jahren festgestellt.
Und jetzt nehme ich morgens und abends mit einer Tablette.
Das heißt, Dylthea Zemm,
oder nehme ich halt morgens und abends eine.
Und wie viel Milligramm, wissen Sie das?
Da steht, Dylthea Zemm 90 ist das.
90.
Okay.
Und haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, also, was ich relativ häufig habe,
das sind Sehenscheidenentzündungen in den Unterarmen.
Und da, also vor allem im Rechten,
weil ich Rechtshänder bin,
und das ist manche, die sich nicht mehr erinnern,
und das ist manchmal,
ja, da muss ich dann so einreiben mit Diclofenacsalve.
Und warum oder das festgestellt bei Ihnen?
Ach, das habe ich eigentlich schon lange eigentlich,
ja, seit meiner Berufsausbildung, also schon 20 Jahre.
Und 20 Jahre.
Wie wurde das behandelt auf Diclofenacsalve?
Ja, ganz am Anfang habe ich das mal bandagiert bekommen.
Und ich habe dann auch so eine Ortese,
die ich trage, so eine Armbandage.
Aber trotzdem kommt das immer wieder.
Okay.
Und ansonsten sind Sie gesund?
Sonst bin ich eigentlich gesund, ja.
Okay.
Also, ich habe noch eine große Dilkésan-Tabletin.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, wenn ich, wenn mir der Arm mal D tut und
ich das nicht mehr aushalten kann,
dann nehme ich wohl auch mal Nuvaldin.
Oder wenn ich mal wirklich schlecht viele Schmerzen habe,
aber das ist ganz, ganz selten.
Und wie viele Milligramm diese Neumarke?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, was ich da gerade zu Hause habe.
Also, ich kann es Ihnen nicht sagen.
Okay.
Und wurde Sie schon mal operiert?
Nee, tatsächlich bin ich noch nie operiert worden.
Okay.
Und rauchen Sie Herr Schäfer?
Seit fünf Jahren rauch ich nicht mehr.
Ich bin sehr stolz draus, ja.
Das haben Sie sehr gut gemacht.
Ja, vorher habe ich viele Jahre ein Päckchen am Tag schon geraucht, ja.
Können Sie sagen genau, wie viele Zigaretten am Tag und wie lange?
Ich bin ein ganz erwachsener Alter, also 22 Jahre, 20 Zigaretten am Tag.
Also eine Schachtel?
Ja, ja.
Und trinken Sie Arcahol?
Ja, zum Feierabend oder zum Abendessen schon.
Oder du hast zwei, drei Gläser Bier trinke ich schon, aber richtig Alkohol der Welten.
Können wir sagen, einmal pro Woche oder da erleden?
Ja, Bier trinke ich schon regelmäßig.
Okay.
Und ich muss auch diese Frage stellen.
Nehmen Sie sonst Gedroge? Nein?
Nein, nein. Also mit Drogen habe ich nur beruflich zu tun, ja.
Okay. Und was machen Sie dann beluflich?
Ja, ich bin bei der Polizei, aber eben aufgrund der Armbeschwerden und so bin ich jetzt nur noch im Dienst.
Polizei. Sind Sie Polizei?
Bei der Polizei, ja. Ich bin Polizist.
Polizistin.
Und haben, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, meine Eltern leben beide noch, ja.
Sie sind aber natürlich schon relativ alt, ja.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Oh, die sind, ja, bitte 80 beide.
Mitte 80, okay.
Und sind Sie gesund?
Ja, bei meinem Vater, da wurde kürzlich die große Zähne amputiert.
Der hatte da so ein Geschwürr dran und das war Durchfutungsstörungen.
Das war dann schon so weit fortgeschritten, dass da nichts mehr zu machen war.
Da hat man dann den Großzähn abgenommen.
Großzähn amputiert worden?
Die ist amputiert worden, ja.
Wegen des Bluthochdrucks?
Nein, wegen aller Durchblutungsstörungen.
Und ist Ihre Mutter gesund?
Ja, eigentlich ist sie so gesund, sie hat nur ein bisschen Probleme,
die hat so eine verkrumpte Wirbelsäule und hat deswegen oft Druck und Schmerzen.
Ich finde, dass sie so ein bisschen nicht so gut ist.
Ja, ich finde, dass sie auch so speziell wackelt.
Also meine Mutter hat eigentlich so organisch nicht viel,
aber sie hat halt einen verkrumpten Rücken und hat deswegen Rücken-Schmerzen.
Also die Wirbelsäule ist ein bisschen verkrumpt.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich habe keine Geschwister, ich war ein Kind.
Und haben Sie Allergie oder lege ich mit den Unterdurchgleichkeiten?
Ja, tatsächlich hat man das mal festgestellt, das war nicht so angenehm.
Ich habe eine Allergie auf Westenstiche, da muss ich also sehr aufpassen.
Ich will das hier aufnehmen.
Und die Allergie?
Die Verbindung ist gerade etwas gestört, können Sie das bitte noch einmal wiederholen?
Haben Sie noch andere Allergie untergeschrieben?
Nein, sonst wüsste ich nicht, dass irgendwas ist.
Okay, und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, aber ich lebe im Augenblick getrennt von meiner Frau.
Sind Sie jetzt in der Trennungspfase?
Wir sind in der Trennungspfase, genau.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder, aber die leben bei meiner Frau.
Und haben Sie vermisst das in beruflichen oder sozialen Nebenen im Zoo?
Ja, natürlich. Also sowohl der Job als auch diese Trennungssituation,
das macht natürlich schon etwas, klar macht das Stress.
Okay, und ich bin fertig mit dem Fragen, haben Sie noch etwas hinbekommen?
Nein, ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was ich Ihnen noch zusätzlich sagen soll.
Okay, und ich habe einen Verdacht auf Nierensteine,
aber das ist eine Verdachtdiagnose,
und ich muss jetzt Ihnen die Tröpfelik untersuchen
und ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Und ich bespreche mit meinem Oberarzt und komme Ihnen zurück
und teile Ihnen mit fast so Tonist.
Ja, das klingt gut, ja.
Was für Untersuchungen machen Sie jetzt?
Ja, ich nehme Ihnen Blut ab.
Ich füge eine Untersuchung durchführe ich.
Ja, okay.
Gut, ja, das ist nicht schmerzhaft, ich habe schon Schmerzen genug.
Ja, wenn Sie möchten, ich gebe Ihnen jetzt einen Schaffmittel.
Schmerzmittel, Entschuldigung.
Ja, wenn Sie mir etwas geben könnten, das wäre schon gut.
Okay, ich organisiere den Gabel.
Okay, Gabel, ja, alles klar.
Ob ich Fieber habe, wird gefragt.
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich auch nicht fieberig.
Haben Sie Blut im Urin benährt?
Ja, habe ich auch gesagt.
Okay, ich habe nicht gehört.
Ja, haben Sie Schüttelflust nach Schweiß?
Ja, das hat ja jetzt erst angefangen vor zwei Stunden,
diese heftigen Schmerzen.
Insofern habe ich noch keine Nacht drüber geschlafen.
Okay, haben Sie Ihnen das derzeit ab oder so genommen?
Nein, mein Gewicht ist eigentlich stabil, ich wüsste nicht mehr,
ich glaube nicht.
Ja, okay, vielen Dank.
Wie viel Wasser trinken Sie täglich?
Oh, Wasser, nicht so viel.
Vielleicht 3,4 Liter, richtiges Wasser.
Normalerweise ich trinke Kaffee und ich trinke Tee
oder auch eben Bier abends, aber Wasser trinke ich nicht viel.
Okay, hatten Sie Probleme mit Wasserlisten?
Früher mit Wasserlisten, wie häufige Wasserlisten oder Brennen?
Das fing erst jetzt eigentlich gestern,
also heute Morgen mit den Brennen an,
oder vielleicht auch schon gestern Abend,
aber das ist noch nicht lange.
Und jetzt eben diese unglaublichen Rückenschmerzen.
Können Sie losstarren?
Frau Dr. Thogruf?
Okay.
Ich höre Sie nicht.
Irgendwo müssen wir wackeln,
oder irgendwas müssen wir wackeln.
Am Kabel, die Verbindung ist gerade nicht gut.
Kann Sie fast nicht verstehen, sagen Sie nochmal hier,
können Sie mich jetzt hören?
Jetzt ist gut.
Vielleicht...
Okay, ich fang an.
Guten Tag Frau Oberärztin.
Heute haben wir einen neuen Patient.
Und ihr Fall möchte ich gerne mit Ihnen besprechen.
Deinen Fall.
Eine neuen Patientin.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich.
Und der Patient heißt Jochen Schäfer.
Er ist 1 Meter 83 groß
und 90 Kilogramm,
wiegt zurzeit 90 Kilogramm.
Und er hat sich bei uns wegen vor 2 Stunden
bestehender,
schlechte Flanken-Schmerzen
mit Ausstrahlung in der regionalen Region vorgestellt.
Und die Schmerzintensität
wurde mit 8 von 10 angegeben.
Außerdem
sei der Patientin vor Gender-Begleitzungs-Symptome aufgefallen.
Den Patientin.
Den Patienten vor Gender-Begleitzungs-Symptome aufgefallen.
Hematurie, Polaxiure, Desiree
und einmaliges Mesis
und Nausea.
Der Patient
habe dieser Schmerz als krampfartig
beschrieb.
Und er...
Er beschrieb.
Und die vegetative Anamnese
ist unauffällig.
Er gab
an, dass er nicht fieberig fühle.
Sich nicht fieberig fühle?
Sich nicht fieberig fühle.
Und die Reise an Amnese
sei leer außer eine Reise zu
Dänemark im Mal.
Und der im Status sei
verständig.
Er habe als Vorerkrankungen
arterielle Hypothonie seit 4 Jahren.
Und seit 20 Jahren
Tendrogenitis
im rechten...
im rechten Unterarm.
Er nehme regelmäßig
Dilthiasen moris und amnese
90 mg ein.
Und bei Bedarf
die Klopfenachsalve und normalen Tabletzen.
Er...
Er sei noch nie operiert worden.
Er habe mit dem Rauchen
vor 5 Jahren aufgehört.
Aber vorher
für
20 Jahre
eine Schachtel täglich geraucht.
Also 20 Packiers.
Und er trinkt Alkohol.
2-3 Gläser pro Woche.
Er
Drogen an Amnese
wurde verneint.
Und ich muss mich mal sehen, wo der Verneint ist.
Und er sei allergisch gegen
Westenstiche.
Der Vater
des Patienten
habe
arterielle Hypothonie
und
eine
große
Zähne amputiert.
Und
die Mutter
des Patienten
habe Skoliose.
Und die beide
sind 80
Jahre.
Und er sei ein sehr kind.
Er sei
Polizistin.
Und er war
Polizei.
Er arbeitet bei der Polizei. Also er ist Polizist.
Polizist.
Er sei Polizist.
Er
sei verheiratet. Aber er lebe
mit seiner Frau.
Er habe 3 gesunde Kinder.
Aber sie leben
bei ihrer Mutter.
Also bei ihrer Mutter, die Kinder.
Und er
gab an, dass er in letzter Zeit
Permet Stress habe.
Und
er hat
eine
Angegabe.
Was könnte es
Alternativ noch sein?
Der Pferdentier
Diagnostisch kommen hier.
Er ist
und eine Appendicitis.
Oder ein ordinerer
Appendicitis.
Ja,
ja.
Was machen Sie Diagnostisch mit den Patienten?
Ja, ich würde
der Patient körperlich untersuchen.
Den Bauch palpieren.
Abwehrspannung
und Druckschmerz
kontrollieren.
Und was noch?
Nicht nur Druckschmerz, sondern auch.
Loslassschmerz.
Auch und das noch.
Und Anzeichen einer Appendicitis
sind die
Patienten aufzusetzen.
Und
Klopfschmerz.
Klopfschmerz
im Nierenlager.
Was können Sie noch fühlen?
Oder spätestens im Ultraschall?
Ja,
ich mache
eine Ultraschalluntersuchung.
Und in Ultraschalluntersuchung würde ich
Schallstein
Schatten
sehen.
Und das noch?
Ich nehme den Patienten Blut ab.
Was lassen Sie untersuchen?
Kleines Blutbild
und in jedem März
kreativ
und Hanzäure.
Und
Therapie, BSD
und Örenstatus.
Und
Örenstatus würde ich auch überprüfen.
beim Urinstatus ist es besonders mit untersuchen lassen.
Ja,
Ältrosythin und Löcosythin nitrit
im Urin.
Und was noch?
Und Christalen.
Ja, genau.
Was könnte drin sein?
Was könnte
Blut?
Welche Christale, was könnte es sein?
Kasju-Kristallen
oder? Alternativ.
Hanzäure-Kristallen.
Ja, Oxalate.
Ja,
und die Stufe der Diagnostik.
Gegebenfalls
eine CT-Untersuchung durchgeführt wurde.
Müsste eine CT-Untersuchung durchgeführt werden.
Ja.
Was wäre, wenn sich Ihre Diagnose bestätigt,
es deuten ja viele Zeichen darauf hin.
Was wäre therapeutisch,
der Weg, den man einschlagen würde?
Was würden Sie mit den Patienten machen?
Als Allgemeinmaßnahmen
würde ich patienten
Flüssigkeit zuvor empfehlen.
Und Beweglichkeit
auch
könnte empfehlen werden.
Und eine Schwierigkeit könnte im Vorhinein sein.
Ja, Beweglichkeit
durch Spontane
Stein.
Ach, so gezielte Bewegung,
um den Stein zu lösen.
Ja.
Aber der hat Schmerzen, ne?
Ja, als Schmerztherapie
Metamisol
und N-A-R
und gegebenenfalls Opioide.
Und
für
Steinverkleinerung
S-W-L-Therapie.
Ja, okay.
Das kommt auch an, die große Steine sind.
Dann hängt die Therapie davon ab.
Wir haben einmal die S-W-L-Therapie.
Was gibt es noch?
Wir haben die S-W-L-Therapie.
Und
offene
Neplototostom
Wenn das zu groß ist, das Ding.
Ja.
Gut, dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden über die
Entwicklung von dem Herrn Schäfer,
wie es dem geht.
Ich habe noch etwas zu tun.
Schauen wir mal, ob Ihre Diagnose richtig ist.
Dann können Sie ja
Ihnen bald Abhilfe verschaffen, dass es besser geht.
Jo, alles klar.
Das mache ich.
Jo.
Ich habe ein bisschen etwas.
Ich habe es nicht gut verstanden.
Weil
einmal war ich verwundert,
dass Sie den Patienten gegenüber, der hat ja gar nicht danach gefragt,
die
Verdachtdiagnose geäußert haben.
Ich war immer ein bisschen davor, das zu machen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das in der Prüfungssituation ist.
Ob das in München gefordert ist,
dass man den Patienten eine Verdachtdiagnose nennt.
Ich denke immer, das Risiko ist zu groß,
dass man sich weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt hat
und muss nachher ein Rückzieher machen.
Das war ganz was anderes.
Das ist ja eigentlich, das wollen wir ja eigentlich nicht.
Gut.
Das ist ja eine Sache.
Ich habe mir aufgefallen,
dass Sie der Obererzin gegenüber das Geburtstatus,
beziehungsweise das Alter des Patienten gar nicht erwähnt haben.
Ja,
dann haben wir einen klassischen Fehler gehabt.
Und zwar
mit den zeitlichen Repositionen.
Es macht wirklich einen großen Unterschied,
welche
man nimmt.
Wenn Sie sagen, er hat sich vorgestellt,
mit vor zwei Stunden bestehenden
Flankenschmerzen,
dann wären die Schmerzen jetzt weg.
Aber das ist ja nicht so.
Er hat ja gejammert und hat sich gekrümmt.
Seit zwei Stunden,
das ist ein erheblicher Unterschied.
Also wirklich gucken Sie sich diese Formulierung noch mal an.
Vor zwei Stunden oder vor zwei Jahren,
dann war da irgendwas, das ist aber jetzt vorbei.
Und wenn etwas seit zwei Stunden
oder seit zwei Jahren oder seit 20 Jahren ist,
dann ist es eben
immer noch aktuell.
Und da muss man auch aufpassen,
zum Beispiel, wann jemand mit dem Brauch und angefangen
oder aufgehört hat.
Oder wann eine Diagnose gestellt worden ist.
Da muss man genau hinhören, was der sagt.
Ob der sagt, ich habe mit 22
aufgehört zu rauchen oder vor 22 Jahren
aufgehört zu rauchen.
Das ist ein Unterschied.
Oder, was weiß ich, wann die Diagnose gestellt wurde.
Und tatsächlich haben Sie sie auch vertan.
Er hat gesagt, 22 Jahre hätte er geraucht.
Ein Zwei-Packiers mehr.
Gut, das ist kein Beinbruch.
Gut, wo Sie sich auch vertan haben,
obwohl Sie da eigentlich nochmal nachgefragt hatten,
der trinkt zwei bis drei Gläser Bier am Tag
und nicht in der Woche.
Das macht auch einen Unterschied aus.
Er hat gesagt, er trinkt jeden Abend zwei, drei Gläser Bier zum Abendbruch
und Feierabend.
Das ist nicht in der Woche.
Dann ist mir auch eine Sache aufgefallen
bei der Familienanamnese.
Da habe ich die sogar schon einmal korrigiert.
Sie haben gesagt, der Vater
hat eine Großzählenamputation rechts,
weil er an Hypertonie gelitten hat.
Den zusammen gibt es ja nun mal nicht.
Er hat gesagt, er hat eine Durchblutungsstörung.
Er hat eine PAVK und hat einen vergangenen C gehabt.
Also ein Ulkos am C oder eine Lesion am C,
die nicht mehr reparabel war.
Mit der Hypertonie war das nicht richtig,
sondern es ist eine PAVK.
Natürlich sagt der Patient nicht
PAVK oder möglicherweise hat er gesagt,
durch Blutungsstörung, aber durch Blutungsstörung,
Bluthochdruck.
Was mir noch aufgefallen ist,
das ist mir beim Fragen nicht so sehr aufgefallen,
aber ist mir nachher in der Anamnese,
im Arztgespräch sehr aufgefallen,
dass sie fast vor jedem Wort
machen.
Das ist wirklich sehr, sehr auffällig
und das ist auch ein bisschen störend.
Versuchen Sie das ein klein bisschen einzuschränken,
häuchen Sie vielleicht nachher noch mal in Ruhe
in das Gespräch rein
und überprüfen Sie das noch mal.
Es ist wirklich sehr, sehr häufig.
Wir machen das alle, aber wir machen es nicht alle so ausgeprägt.
Ich weiß, ich bin da überhaupt nicht frei.
Ich mache auch oft zwischendurch,
genau wie ich auch Fehler mache in der Sprache.
Jeder macht eigentlich so im Alltags-
in der Alltagssprache Fehler.
Wir sprechen nicht perfekt, nur dieses permanente,
also eigentlich vor jeder Angabe
ist ein bisschen lästig.
Gut.
Und ansonsten, wenn so ganz dolle Grammatik-Sachen kamen,
bin ich ja eigentlich immer gleich eingestiegen.
Das haben Sie gemerkt, ich habe Sie dann praktisch
von außen korrigiert.
Ich bin aus der Rolle rausgefallen
und habe Ihnen gesagt, wie es richtig heißt.
Da haben wir das gar nicht alles,
weil man das gar nicht alles immer notieren kann.
Gut.
Es ist tatsächlich noch so ein bisschen überarbeitungsbedarf,
würde ich mal sagen.
V.a. wirklich achten Sie gut darauf,
dass Sie wirklich präzise die Angaben übertragen.
Sie 2-3 Bier pro Tag oder pro Woche.
Und was hatten wir noch?
Ja, und hier die Hypertonie statt PR-Propagat.
Das sind schon Sachen, das ist auch relativ wichtig.
Und da könnten auch Nachdrahten kommen.
Wo Sie eigentlich überhaupt keine Probleme hatten,
war dann die Anleitung,
die Sie dann in der Sprache haben,
die Sie dann überhaupt keine Probleme hatten,
war dann die Diagnostik und die Therapie.
Da wussten sie ja genau, was zu tun ist
und haben eigentlich keine Wünsche offen gelassen.
Abgesehen, wie gesagt,
von den sprachlichen Geschichten,
die nicht immer so top waren.
Gut.
Okay, so viel für heute.
Jetzt muss ich noch Dr. Pupil fragen,
haben Sie ein Stimmungsbild bekommen,
wie mein Angebot für nächsten Mittwoch angenommen wird?